Shawn Salisbury Sports Talk 790 in
Houston their morning drive host former
NFL quarterback I was gonna have you on
to talk about the DeAndre Hopkins deal
let me ask you about Tom Brady what do
you think happened here you know what
Dad it's wet and we don't have any
sports to talk about Dewey good gracious
you know what Dan I think that in it got
down to if you're Brady you're waiting
to walk into bills office and have him
make you an offer meaning what kind of
players you gonna supply me what are our
chances to continue the Superbowl type
of run and what are you gonna pay me and
you may I heard you he's one of the very
few unlike the guy here Bill O'Brien who
makes decisions not on emotions but what
he thinks and every time whether it's
lawyer Milloy and even Brady's not
immune to it Malloy Thai law Richard
Seymour Britt all those guys when he
thinks that okay your times about up no
matter who you are I think Tom wanted an
offer that he couldn't refuse and I
think bill at this point in time without
emotion being involved wanted to move on
and made him an offer he could refuse
and that's why Brady today made the
announcement I think he was waiting for
them to grasp him and hug him and I
don't think so and I think bill when he
goes up with his press conference is
gonna do what he does this is it is Tom
did good we'll move on and you won't see
one ounce of emotion in it honest to god
nineteen years later it's shocking it's
gonna be weird but if it happens to rice
and Joe Montana it can happen to Tom
Brady where do you think you'll end up
Dan for me and I know the best situation
really if you're if you're the cult let
me just throw this out there and I know
Frank Reich and Philip Rivers and
they're there how they've been together
but if you're the cults and you love
Philip Rivers why wouldn't you love Tom
Brady got wide receivers you got weapons
you got an offensive line where Tom done
after me offensive line will let him sit
his feet in the pocket and deliver
mechanically the best guy we've ever had
at quarterback they can run the ball
efficiently good play caller good
front-office got money went got
themselves some help up front so there's
doubt on the defensive line still got
two draft picks and collateral they got
money to pay Tom Brady if you love
Phillip Rivers and you want a veteran
why wouldn't you at least entertain the
offer that you're the opportunity at
Tom Brady he's better than Phillip
Rivers and then well there's Bruce
Arians who'd be fun to work with but
they're not super bowl ready although
he'd have weapons
the Chargers you still got to deal with
mahomes the Raiders Jon Gruden Falls
heck Jon Gruden love me one second wants
Brady the neck he falls in that'll love
with quarterback so maybe Brady and then
I am still not for just for the hell of
it I'm still not ruling out that the San
Francisco 49ers trades doing it weapons
with that trade getting a you know
another first-round draft pick I gotta
believe they're at least gonna talk to
Tom even though it's probably crazy but
the best situation for him as it stands
there's no questions the Indianapolis
Colts the question is how interested are
they in him yeah I wondered about that
that you play half your game indoors
you've got a good offensive line you
like the coach he's a former quarterback
and you've got some weapons there your
defense is pretty good I and you're
right if you're gonna if you're gonna
take a flyer on Phillip Rivers then why
not least do a drive-by on Tom Brady the
Chargers part of this I understand what
the weapons there and maybe that's the
lifestyle part of this that he's he's
mentioned in his tweet Tampa Bay
i I think Tampa Bay is sneaky good but I
just I I just don't know cuz you know we
don't know what the Falcons are
Carolina's in a rebuild you're still
gonna have to deal with the Saints there
but you know Tampa could be a playoff
team with the right quarterback there
and you've got a lot of weapons there
but you know you start to troubleshoot
this for Brady and it feels like the
Chargers make the most sense for
everything that he's talking about
reading between the lines and that in a
production yeah all those things to move
West closer to where he grew up even
though it's Northern California Dan you
make a good mention about Tampa with
those weapons and Bruce Arians is great
not just good great with quarterbacks
and part of Tom's criteria is to be work
with a coach and I don't know if this
was a dig that he could actually work
with at this point in time and Bruce
would love it you know supposedly they
and the Chargers have already made
thirty million dollar kind of offers to
Tom Brady but it would seem logical to
go west and the Chargers and the one
thing that is Tom think that he can get
through Kansas City and Mahone's they do
have weapons hunter Henry if he's
healthy they got some players Keenan
Allen the question is will they sure
that
offensive line up so he can set his feet
so all of them have a strength but
there's also weaknesses but what's Brady
always done then he's always taken the
weakness and made it better and the
question is in Tampa or Los Angeles with
the Chargers candy he'll have options I
think they're more limited than he
thought but Tom Brady is gonna make an
impact I cannot believe we're sitting
here talking about today that Tom Brady
is going to be playing somewhere else
it's absolutely it's baffling to me but
you know what now New England's got to
go on the hunt wouldn't it be funny if
Jimmy Garoppolo ended up back there for
a second-round pick
yeah I just don't see that happening and
maybe gonna happen I I think I thought
Andy Dalton all along was sort of a
safeguard and if you if you got Teddy
Bridgewater great if you know I just
don't know enough about Jared Stidham
other than what I saw when he was in
college but then right most guys who
were in the NFL looked pretty good in
college we're talking to Shawn Salisbury
Sports Talk 790 Houston morning Drive
host and of course former NFL
quarterback the DeAndre Hopkins deal to
Arizona House is playing locally
horrible Dan it is I've tried over the
since Bill's been here I wonder how hard
it is for those guys to coach and and
and it's difficult I've tried almost I
don't want to say champion his cause but
defend him a little bit then I cannot
there you could give me a million bucks
that I can't defend this trade when I
heard about this yesterday my head first
of all exploded fortunate I got it back
before I came home with you but they
made know what you're doing is how do
you stand up in front of your team and
say we got better you've got a superstar
quarterback who's a sacred cow you made
him worse you didn't improve any
weakness David Johnson is a guy and you
traded that guy who is the best football
player consistently on the Texans that's
including Watson right now is DeAndre
Hopkins hall-of-famer you you you don't
have a number one receiver you have two
of those guys that are two of the three
receivers and stills and we'll fuller
that spend a lot of time watching from
the sidelines potential for will fuller
yes but doesn't play a full season and
you got rid of your best football player
and you've got a fourth a second and you
you've got a aging running backs that
David Johnson's fault but he's a guy
that he's a guy dance
think about this if you woke up this
morning and I told you Michael Thomas
and the Saints traded Michael Thomas and
a fourth round pick to the Texans for
Duke Johnson and a second round pick and
they threw in a fourth rounder what
would you do do you think they did you'd
call in the National Guard right those
are the two best receivers like that's
what this is
you lost respect to players you cut off
the fan you basically cut the knees off
of a franchise and he's already been one
of those guys that people have not liked
here I think Bill O'Brien the respect
factor he's not going to be able to
stand in front of that team and tell
them they got better he can't handle a
really really good player this
opposition that maybe doesn't get along
with you mentioned emotion Bill
Belichick doesn't act on emotion Bill
O'Brien does yet he doesn't want his
players to Bill O'Brien lost a lot of
respect I think in that locker room
yesterday this is this bad a trait as
this city's ever seen football wise yeah
you know I saw this on bleacher report
Mike tenure rights the Texans have to
address Bill O'Brien situation Bill
O'Brien is a stager staggeringly
terrible general manager he's also an
awful head coach as illustrated by many
of his suspect decisions in the Texans
blowing a 24-point lead to lose to the
Chiefs in the AFC divisional round
despite his shortcomings as a game
planner play caller O'Brien has a 52 and
44 head coaching record and has led the
Texans to the playoffs four times in six
years but I just I don't know what the
rationale is will he hold a press
conference and talk about this no it'll
be a while Dan he'll let it clear and if
he does it'll be said I'm not going to
discuss a guy's personal or my
relationship with DeAndre Hopkins or
what hey he'll go through that here's
the thing Dan normally when you run
these things by you run them by an owner
with Cal McNair who's to blame on this
also Bill's got so much power in this
organization he said he walked up those
steps in my opinion and what's done and
said here's what we're doing not do you
approve of this trade see what Bill
O'Brien the coach should have done is
punch the general manager right in the
face the problem is he'd have to do with
the mirror because it's the same guy and
imagine this Dan if bill was a coach
somewhere else where he didn't have
power and he was told that this trade
was going down
wouldn't he walk into the general
manager and owners obviously what are
you doing so yes while he's won games
the seed and he got a quarterback like
Watson it's not just to get to the
playoffs it's to get deep and to be able
to play in February he's lost a lot of
respect that he's been questioned as a
play caller and a coach he's got too
much power and unfortunately power ego
and narcissistic attitudes ruin
relationships ruined businesses and
ruined football teams he is the most
despised man in this town right now let
me ask you about the cowboy situation
with dak Prescott of Amari Cooper got
paid
Zeke Elliott got paid there are a lot of
guys who got paid and dak Prescott is
sitting there going wait a minute here I
know he's getting fair market value in
fact I think what he's being offered is
fair to his talent level that he is he's
not Russell Wilson
he's not a super bowl-winning
quarterback but he's gonna make more
than Jerrod golf is or Carson Wentz that
seems to be fair market values so where
do you stand on the Cowboys with dak
Prescott you know Dan and I've said it
on your show I think when I said I felt
last year I felt he was underappreciated
or underrated and I think that he needed
to put up numbers to prove to people he
wasn't just a guy who threw it 24 times
and had to have a great running game for
him to succeed
statistically well he did now the next
level is him for to win for him to win
and to carry teams when ok you know when
doing the running backs out or the wide
receivers a little banged up for the
defense I'm with you the offer they made
seems at least on the surface appears to
me seems to be pretty good but you know
what Danny's in a position that's
obviously premium he isn't going
anywhere he put the franchise tag on him
and think what the salary cap what the
CBA is going to happen it's going to go
up he's going to make a 35 million bucks
Dan he just is now are people going to
say he's overpaid probably but that's
what we do listen peg did just look at
the Titans and what they paid Tannehill
it didn't 220 million is not the norm
anymore
28 to 30 million is so I'm with you on
the value but he's looking at it fan
what's your option dude what is your
option Gerry he will eventually get paid
and it'll be a lot in for a minute he'll
be the highest-paid
quarterback in NFL history until the
homes are until Watson comes around but
I agree with you but you know what Dan
you're worth which you can negotiate and
the Cowboys are not going to let him go
he will be the starting quarterback for
the Cowboys and he will get paid whether
it's this year or when the franchise tag
is done he's going to be making close to
35 million or more over the course of a
contract and a lot of it's going to be
guaranteed great to talk to you bud
thanks for joining us Sean always great
to be on with your brother thank you
enjoy that Shawn Salisbury morning Drive
host on sports talks 790